Memorial center Hassan hassanovic
listens to the testimonies of survivors
for him their accounts are key to
preserving memories
his father and brother were killed in
the genocide and he knows that talking
about trauma is the first step in
healing
he says survivors can't fully recover
while the genocide is still denied by
some
living in circumstances where genocide
is denied and minimized it is difficult
to talk about reconciliation and
transitional justice but also healing
that is healing wounds
more than 8 300 people were killed in
the genocide and strep brunitza 28 years
ago but genocide survivors are not the
only ones who carry trauma
psychologists say trauma is passed down
from generation to generation and even
those born after the war feel the
consequences psychological help is
crucial but neglected they say
when we talk about war suffering and
Trauma there is a special story about
the families of the missing and that
uncertain loss because until you find
the body the morning process cannot move
forward the international Committee of
the Red Cross which has long been
involved in the search for the
Disappeared says families deserve
psychological help but institutional
help is more important
all levels of government must open
archives and make available information
and ensure that the institute for the
missing has sufficient funds and
resources to fulfill its mandate more
than 7 600 missing people are still
being searched for in Bosnian
Herzegovina among them are 800 victims
from strebrenitza even though it's 28
years since the war ended thousands of
their relatives cannot stop facing the
pasta